Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Da un progettista che si occupa
di innovazione di prodotto,
credo che ci si immagini
che parli di futuro.
Io invece vorrei fare, con voi,
un piccolo esperimento:
ma solo per una manciata di minuti,
quindi tranquilli.
Vorrei portarvi nel passato.
Vorrei portarvi indietro di 50-60 anni,
più o meno alla mia data di nascita
e io sono classe 2014
anno interessante
perché in quello stesso anno,
dal punto di vista dell'innovazione,
venne proposto il primo cellulare
con una tecnologia capace di -
con una batteria
capace di autoalimentarsi.
Era un prodotto molto costoso,
quindi di lusso.
Costava circa quanto lo stipendio
mensile di un manager.
E nello stesso anno, per coincidenza,
era uscita la prima automobile
totalmente stampata in stampa digitale:
qui ne vediamo una
delle fasi di stampaggio, lo chassis.
E si chiamava Strati.
Era mitica, per noi italiani, divenne
mitica perché io ero appena nata
perché era stata progettata
e aveva un nome italiano
anche se i produttori
erano una di quelle microfabbriche
che negli Stati Uniti già stavano operando
ed erano, anzi, l'azienda
pioniera in questo campo
nel produrre con la
tecnologia digitale automobili.
"Spesso è aggiustando le cose
che capiamo come le cose funzionano"
scriveva qualche anno prima,
nel 2008, Richard Sennett
nel suo "L'uomo artigiano",
un libro che consiglio a tutti di leggere
ma che a me serve, qui,
soltanto per ricordarci
che quelli erano gli anni
nel quale si era compiuto quel giro di boa
che significava il passaggio
da una cultura meccanica,
seguitemi in questo,
nella quale gli oggetti,
per quanto complessi,
erano comunque composti di parti
che in qualche modo erano riconoscibili,
a una cultura elettronica
nella quale, invece,
complessità, miniaturizzazione
e una serie di eventi
che in parte vedremo insieme oggi
avevano portato a rendere gli oggetti
sempre più facili da utilizzare,
ma sempre meno comprensibili
nel come erano fatti.
E in quegli stessi anni,
invisibile, piuttosto silenziosa
partì anche una rivolta
che a me oggi piace chiamare
la "rivolta degli smontatori",
perché era una rivolta
che era partita nelle azioni
degli attivisti sociali di quartiere
che in qualche modo
volevano riappropriarsi
del destino degli oggetti che erano dati,
che era dato di utilizzare,
cioè quelli dell'elettronica;
ma aveva avuto un "moltiplicatore virale",
si dice, via Internet,
attraverso le comunità dei più giovani
che erano invece abituati
a lavorare online
e a scambiarsi informazioni online
come dei nuovi apprendisti.
Tranquilli, per fortuna siamo
nel 2014, non siamo nel 2060:
perché nessuno di noi sa
che cosa accadrà, veramente, nel futuro.
Il futuro, certe volte,
un pochino ci spaventa:
non sappiamo esattamente
cosa potràsuccedere domani,
ma possiamo cogliere,
nel presente di oggi,
dei segni di cambiamento
che in qualche modo potrebbero essere
dei semi di futuro.
Possiamo anche prendere lezioni
dall'esperienza del passato,
purché siamo disposti a riattualizzarle.
E allora è qui che vi vorrei portare
un pochino dentro questa ipotesi
del che cos'è che divide
il presente di oggi
da un domani dove, probabilmente,
avere cura delle cose,
manutenerle, ripararle,
farle durare a lungo
potrebbe diventare
qualcosa di più o meno simile
ad una tranquilla, indiscussa -
anzi, forse necessaria normalità.
Ed è la domanda che io mi sono fatta,
e me la sono fatta
perché lavoro con i prodotti,
lavoro con le aziende,
per cercare di capire se era vero
dai segnali che coglievo,
appunto, in questa rete,
appunto in questo mondo delle innovazioni
che la domanda della riparabilità,
in qualche modo,
per varie vicende era in crescita;
e se questa crescita,
dovuta ai protagonisti che la volevano,
in qualche modo riportare in campo,
stava cambiando inaspettatamente,
ancora in sotterranea,
i destini degli oggetti
e in qualche modo, il modo
con il quale progettiamo, produciamo
e poi usiamo gli oggetti.
E quindi siamo andati a guardare,
io con il mio studio
perché questa ricerca
è assolutamente autofinanziata,
ma che ha ricevuto il patrocinio dell'ADI,
cioè l'Associazione del Design
Industriale Italiano,
come dire, andiamo avanti
a capire che cosa succede,
abbiamo guardato un po' a tutti,
non solamente ai designer
o agli imprenditori più visionari,
non solamente agli scienziati,
non solo agli innovatori,
ma un po' a tutti;
e quindi anche agli attori, a quelli
che si chiamano gli attori sociali,
e così ci siamo accorti
che per lo meno è giàaccaduto
che l'idea di ritornare a pensare
a come le cose sono fatte
è un fatto giàintragenerazionale
e intraculturale.
Cosa vuol dire questo?
Vuol dire che i paesi in crescita,
quando introducono delle nuove tecnologie,
trovano del tutto naturale,
anzi necessario,
istruire i propri tecnici,
i propri ingegneri,
a costruire, manutenere
e poi sapere riparare nel tempo,
nei propri villaggi di origine,
le tecnologie che hanno installato.
È intragenerazionale
perché in un momento molto particolare,
in cui chi è uscito, magari troppo presto,
dal mondo del lavoro,
ed è ancora quella generazione
ricchissima di tante abilità manuali,
ha incominciato proprio così:
nelle atmosfere di quartiere,
che qualcuno oggi ci ha fatto rivivere,
ha incominciato a mettere a disposizione
i suoi saperi del fare,
per riparare il tostapane;
ma ha fatto un passo in più,
l'ha condiviso con i più giovani.
Perché i più giovani, invece,
che nel mondo del lavoro
ancora non sono entrati,
sono abituatissimi ad usare la tecnologia
sono abituati ad usare
l'elettronica di consumo
e sanno anche che questi oggetti
sono costosissimi.
Quindi, per loro,
scambiarsi informazioni è vitale
a capire come farli usare
il più a lungo possibile.
E questo ha fatto entrare queste realtà,
questo è un pochino più inaspettato,
nella pancia delle aziende.
Una di queste "Repair Community" londinese
oggi fa dei corsi di formazione
per le banche londinesi
o per le multinazionali
dell'Information Technology,
perché all'interno di una politica
di welfare aziendale
è interessante far capire
ai propri dipendenti,
dargli coscienza della tecnologia
che stanno utilizzando.
Ma il Faidate 2.0, chiamiamolo così,
tanto per dire che sono
dei nuovi apprendisti,
che sono dei nuovi artigiani,
più lungimirante e anche più abile,
più serio, più approfondito,
in realtà, mettendo in piedi
le proprie guide online
per la riparazione di qualunque cosa
alla quale danno il contributo
gli utenti della rete
spiegando, facendo, riprovando,
con la costruzione dei loro utensili,
bellissimi da un punto
di vista del design,
anche se non sono dei designer,
sono degli ingegneri informatici;
e così precisi,
con una precisione chirurgica,
che non solo diventano il modo
per denunciare il fatto
che una semplice vite fino a ieri
oggi è diventato un modo
per non farci entrare
all'interno degli oggetti,
quindi costruiscono gli utensili
per renderlo possibile;
ma più che un aspetto pratico,
il vero cambiamento
che loro stanno portando
è che ci stanno spostando, nuovamente,
verso un mondo materiale
che avevamo in parte dimenticato
e quindi hanno aperto l'immaginazione.
Allora la pratica del riparare,
del "riparare dinamico" si dice oggi
ci porta in realtàla libertà,
e anche la voglia
di capire un po' meglio
come le cose sono fatte
e quindi è molto vicina
a farci porre delle domande,
a chi progetta e a chi produce,
di ripensare per lo meno alla logica
con la quale le cose vengono prodotte.
Questi signori si sono guadagnati
una tale autorevolezza
che le aziende più
lungimiranti, semplicemente,
che vogliono dare qualche cosa
di più interessante e di più nuovo
ai propri utilizzatori
o che magari, all'interno di politiche
di responsabilità sociale o ambientale,
vogliono essere più efficaci
sul piano dell'uso,
cioè dopo il momento del consumo,
stanno utilizzando questi signori
e la loro esperienza
per costruire anche
dei servizi sul prodotto,
per cambiare i prodotti
mentre si stanno sviluppando:
per esempio, rendendoli più riparabili.
Così oggi ci troviamo
con delle guide online
dentro i siti dei produttori,
magari di abbigliamento outdoor,
non un prodotto ad alta tecnologia
come il cellulare,
ma questa cultura dei maker sta portando
anche un paio di altri
suggerimenti alle aziende
che forse vanno un pochino più osservati.
Per esempio, forse alcuni di voi,
qui, che sono studenti,
ne avranno sicuramente sentito parlare:
accanto al download della musica,
oggi possiamo fare il download del design,
che vuol dire che possiamo
scaricarci dei file -
si dice delle "matematiche",
diciamo noi tecnici:
in realtà,di fatto, dei disegni.
Se poi siamo anche capaci
di intervenire su questi disegni,
o anche se non lo siamo,
possiamo anche andare
nel server sotto casa
che ha una stampante digitale
e stamparci piccoli pezzi.
Quindi, in senso positivo,
si sta aprendo l'idea
che potremmo fare il download dei ricambi
se tutte queste innovazioni
entrassero, o stanno entrando,
in questo presente di domani,
nel DNA dei prodotti;
e anche restando vicino
a una cultura del riparare,
in qualche modo dell'interessarci
anche di cosa succede dopo,
significa almeno due cose:
che tutto diventa più flessibile,
il prodotto è più flessibile;
e che tutto diventa più partecipativo.
Stanno nascendo prodotti più accessibli?
Sì, ma questo non vuol dire soltanto
che ci posso andare dentro
per toglierli dei componenti.
Vuol dire, magari,
che posso cambiare
una parte fisica del prodotto,
quando mi serve, senza chiedere
l'assistenza specializzata.
Nei prodotti aggiornabili,
il passo è breve:
a quel punto, perché cambiare
il mio cellulare?
Prima avevo solo una fotocamera,
ora voglio una videocamera:
cambio il pezzo e glielo metto.
E questo potremmo farlo
anche nelle lavatrici,
nelle lavastoviglie;
o magari avere una stampante
che diventa una lavastoviglie.
Sembra anche questo futuro:
ma in realtà, per esempio,
in alcune Universitàaustraliane,
quest'esperienza, con la Xerox,
giàsi sta facendo.
E poi, che forse è più interessante,
e ci piace di più portare
l'attenzione su questo,
se guardiamo così tanto
ai nuovi riparatori,
dei prodotti più semplificati:
eh sì, dice bello, facciamo semplice
nella epoca meccanica fare semplice
era un'operazione
oggi lo è in termini diversi.
Certo, ma la semplificazione
non è solo in termini fisici,
non sono solo prodotti
più semplici da aprire:
sono anche prodotti più semplici,
perché sono più trasparenti;
e quindi prodotti più etici.
E allora, questo mondo della riparazione,
della nuova riparazione,
sta aprendo un potenziale di innovazione
molto interessante,
che va dai chimici che studiano materiali,
che sono autoriparanti,
ma anche sul piano delle poetiche
si stanno mettendo in campo
delle nuove estetiche;
e queste nuove sfide si saldano, poi,
con chi sta pensando
a delle produzioni etiche e sostenibili
e in qualche modo
vuole dare un contributo,
una svolta sul piano del consumo.
E tutte queste innovazioni fantastiche,
l'entusiasmo che abbiamo
per le innovazioni, per la tecnologia,
per l'elettronica, per il digitale,
insomma per quell'Internet delle Cose,
ci potrebbe, in realtà, portare
anche ad un accorciamento
del tempo che passa
tra la fascinazione e la noia.
E poi ci sono i numeri:
sempre nel 2014, bellissimo
chi è nato questo anno,
penso in autunno, siamo diventati
7,2 miliardi di persone nella Terra.
Ma un altro dato
che non si conosce così tanto
è che siamo stati superati dalle SIM:
cioè ci sono più accessi mobili,
credo 7,27 miliardi
di accessi mobili nel mondo,
che persone.
E allora, se nel 2060 ci dicono
che saremo nove miliardi di persone,
sicuramente entro il secolo [saremo]
tra i 10 e gli 11 miliardi di persone.
Noi abbiamo davanti un'iperbole,
nei termini del consumo,
o una parabola?
Anche perché alcuni aspetti,
come la personalizzazione di massa,
che la stampa digitale ci mette davanti
ci può risolvere delle problematiche
funzionali "ad personam";
però, allo stesso tempo,
potrebbe far aumentare la stupidità,
cioè quell'entusiasmo un po' stupido,
che porta subito alla noia,
che ci fa costruire gli oggetti
che vogliamo quando vogliamo.
Poco importa se, dopo dieci minuti,
non ci interessano più.
E allora andiamo un po' al passato,
perché noi abbiamo un'eredità
che è il design italiano,
le fabbriche italiane del design,
e questa frase di Achille Castiglioni
che dice più o meno:
"Prima di capire cosa dobbiamo fare,
capiamo invece cosa non dobbiamo fare."
Lui la diceva più o meno negli anni '60:
e oggi cosa possiamo fare,
quale può essere veramente
il contributo del design?
Quello che davvero
dobbiamo riattualizzare,
noi come progettisti,
i produttori e gli utilizzatori,
è il senso del rispetto,
perché la cultura delle riparazione -
o comunque, diciamola meglio,
la cultura del fare,
che riporta l'attenzione
sulla cultura del fare-
è qualcosa che in fondo
ci riporta a un'idea
di rispetto per il fare
che è stata tutta la nostra cultura
scientifica e umanistica
dal '700 illuminista,
pensiamo all'Encyclopédie
di Diderot e D'Alembert,
che era proprio la nostra cultura europea,
fino all'altro ieri.
Ma se riusciamo soltanto
a riportare in qualche modo
il rispetto nel 'come' sono fatte le cose
perché sulle eccellenze del fare
è giocata la qualitàdelle cose
ma soprattutto è giocata
la qualità"alta",
quella che il paradosso del lusso
ci ha fatto perdere
un po' troppo di vista.
Ma anche un rispetto
per altre dimensioni del fare
che sono legate, per esempio,
alla pazienza, alla costanza nel tempo.
E poi il rispetto per la bellezza,
che ho sentito citare prima,
mi ha veramente dato energia.
Ma per quale bellezza?
Beh per lo meno rispetto
alla sua non banalizzazione:
perché la bellezza
è un valore, non è un prezzo.
E allora,
non so quanti di voi, usciti di qui,
andranno a guardare le vitine
del proprio ultimo modello sei
non diciamo di quale marca,
per scoprire che non sono solo piccole,
ma sono pentalobate,
e quindi non lo trovate
l'utensile per aprirle
se non lo comprate
dai riparatori della iFixit.
Ma forse anche ripensano
che questo verbo riparare,
che si dice allo stesso modo
in tutte le principali lingue europee,
e quindi in tutte le lingue
del nostro benedetto
Occidente industrializzato,
deriva, ha una matrice latina,
che è la matrice
della nostra lingua italiana,
che è Re-parare.
E quindi ci ricorda che, in fondo,
non è tanto una questione solo materiale.
Non si tratta solo
di rimettere a posto, di rimediare:
significa anche sapere difendere,
cioè in qualche modo ridare valore
a come sono fatte le cose,
perché le cose che sono state fatte
le abbiamo dovute produrre noi.
(Applausi)